[Music]
I've got just a few days left to crank
the enemy's cooking this country has
nearly three thousand kilometres of
coastline so I'm heading to the pretty
fishing village of plant yet to see what
they do with seafood this morning I'm on
my way to meet a bunch of local
fishermen who fish on a nightly basis
for the most amazing squid office
phenomenal coastline I'm hooking up with
Doc Chung a chef who works wonders with
seafood how are you like everyone else
here Duke likes his food as fresh as
possible and he's offered to take me
fishing they're not really boats though
are they oh yeah bathtubs right oh this
bad there's tubs in by this basket boat
a few more words in there it goes on
there has to be a basket case what are
they these are to go fishing to bring in
squid shrimp yeah and the engine whirs
engine go oh these bamboo boats have
been used by squid fishermen for
generations and before I go out fishing
I've got to learn how it's done back and
forth back and forth
powder push to go forward basically it
looks effortless it looks like it
doesn't he's like dizzy clothes with a
wad there now get your stand
get your kung-fu stand in this is
probably the most difficult Road I've
ever done 40 minutes later they seem to
think I'm getting the hang of it no I'm
not convinced
plastic case what's he saying you're in
for a race dude Oh mr. basket case he
wants a race can I just at least have a
five meter head star hotel you basket
cases basket fisherman on your marks get
set go
[Applause]
it's back to beginners class for me I'm
stuck in Reverse [ __ ] come on excuse me
oh come a lift
boats full of water that's hard bloody
hard I'm excited about catching squid
but not in a [ __ ] wicker basket now
the best time to catch squid is at night
and as the day ends the fleet get down
to business this is incredible
they're now getting their Tinney lamps
set up and the idea to like the mantle
get a nice and bright turn it around and
that will start to attract the squid
that's my boat
and that will their duck show me your
squid in ten minutes okay yeah thirty
here duck yes what do they do out here
all night rice wine freshly cooked squid
right on top of here man they cook the
squid on top of the incredible don't
their wives miss them there I've missed
the squid more than they were the
husband of Jesus come on baby
where are these squids after two hours I
haven't got a bite
any pooling go ahead nothing
but the pros have landed some beauties
look at that does it
I've never seen squid that fresh and now
they do I'm gonna clean it up now
now seafood supremo Duke is going to
show me a delicious Vietnamese favourite
stop squid
so we basically good weekend is use all
of it this is their little beach beach
right here vietnamese loves it it's a
tooth it's a tooth the outside of it
it's like the membrane doctor to hold
the tooth together so it's crunchy how
nice Vietnamese love Sexy's texture and
English it's like eating a gum there we
go yeah nice so from snake bones to gums
yeah
holy moly squid shooting man according
European they usually eat that ink you
know make look like reciprocity or
something like that you use it here no
not yet wow that's fantastic news don't
give them idea that's the first time in
Vietnam
okay I found something you don't eat
squid ink
I found something the Brits eat that the
Vietnamese don't but for me this complex
squid dish beets had deep fried version
any day
50 50 year tentacles chopped up I'm
Prince of sin to the poor right good
what a guy yep and the word ginger as
well
we're gonna stuff this squid and a
little bit of fish sauce I'm a major put
fish sauce in there well I mean if you
don't put cook fish sauce in Vietnam
then you use some sort of like
foreigners here there and chopping in
there please and now the place of the
sauce is ginger garlic and onion ginger
garlic onion they were fantastic
nice touch accordin I've just a few
squids in my time right
having [ __ ] court many why'd you try
hard sire I can't wait to dig in and to
see if the sea dogs are as impressed
with Duke's dish as I am I've got the
biggest piece of squid in da house the
squizzle pile of cold beer boy let the
gammon more day it's perfect
thank you for being so brilliant and so
patient amazing come tackle with
pleasure to see you here and you're not
drunk is that the same stuff from these
lanterns
oh yeah mr. Tay congratulations
honestly balls of steel it's been an
amazing day getting out to see and
cooking the catch is as simple as it
gets and I've loved getting back to
basics I didn't grow up with much money
around the table we act in a very humble
way but here even if you haven't got
much money you eat in an amazing way a
very fresh way they don't realize to
what a great standard they eat at so
cheaply I tell them I'm a lot better in
the kitchen than I am at rowing chairs